so I'm going to have some sort of wrap up
and highlights of this extremely erratic behavior
from our [inaudible]
over the weekend. This includes continuing
the farce that is sharpie gate. This includes
authoritarian demands that Noah not contradict,
n o a that is Noah, not contradicts his claims
about Hurricane Dorian putting Alabama at
risk. But before we even get to that cause,
I do want to run through some of those stories
a little bit. We're now learning and it makes
sense that Donald Trump's own advisors, the
Brown nosing sycophants who will stand behind
the guy until the most extenuating and absurd
circumstances make it all but impossible to
defend him. Even Trump's own advisors are
starting to privately say that they're worried
about Donald Trump's mental state after this
last week of just outrageously erratic and
volatile behavior. So we see the public part,
the unhinged tweet storms, the confused slow
speeches, while he seems to be gripping the
poll of the electorate and wrestling with
his own tongue, the angry speeches.
But that's just the public side. And there's
the behind the scenes, which is an entire
other situation going on privately, which
Donald Trump's aids are now coming clean about.
Trump's aids and confidants are now telling
business insider that he is experiencing bipolar
mood changes and I don't mean bipolar in the
psychiatric sense. I mean bipolar in terms
of up and down, up and down mood changes from
one minute to the next based sometimes merely
on seeing a news headline that he doesn't
like. This guy is so triggerable and so volatile
that sometimes according to his own aides
and advisors, his entire schedule will be
changed because he sees some negative story
about him, which sends him into a complete
and total tailspin such that he's enabled
to do or unwilling to do anything for the
rest of the day. Quote from one Republican
strategist who is frequently in contact with
the White House, he's deteriorating in plain
sight.
We see it publicly, right? Just by itself.
What we see publicly would be enough to confirm
that this is someone who is temperamentally
unfit to be president of the United States.
And Aids are saying that the public component
is nothing compared to the private component.
A person who's close, who was close to Donald
Trump's legal team during the Russia investigation
told business insider that Trump's public
statements were, quote nothing compared to
what he's like behind closed doors. The Alabama
thing, which been in, because we'll continue
talking about it a little bit, is particularly
worrying to them because it could have all
been prevented by saying, oh, I mentioned
Alabama could have been hit by the hurricane.
Turns out Hurricane Dorian wasn't heading
there. We should all be glad about that, that
people in Alabama weren't in harm's way. We're
going to work on helping the people who were
in harm's way.
Instead, it has been this endless never ending,
uh, lies and cover ups, including drawing
on a hurricane map with a sharpie, which we
talked about last week. So this is no longer
about Donald Trump lying. Trump's aides and
confidence are saying everyone is used to
the lies already sad that we've become completely
accustomed to that. But the this Alabama thing
has crossed over to another level altogether
that is too to them, to quote them, quote
a deterioration in plain sight, 15 tweets
and five maps about the Alabama hurricane
fiasco. And this is unfortunately, and I mean
that it's not a surprise to anyone who's been
watching or listening to my program and paying
attention to this. He's been getting worse
and worse and worse for years now. And he
controls nuclear weapons and geopolitics and
our relationships to every historical world
ally of importance to the United States. If
he merely stays on the same trajectory, like
nothing gets worse and nothing accelerates,
he just stays on the same decline trajectory
between now and election day.
Imagine what we will be dealing with by November
of 2020 especially if his polling numbers
don't improve and an even more deteriorated.
Donald Trump believes that he's likely to
lose in November of 2020 this will become
the stuff of nightmares and just imagine if
he starts to think that as a result of losing
in November of 2020 he might end up indicted.
It will be more outrageous than we can likely
imagine. He will be desperate to prove non-existent
voter fraud. He will be desperate to avoid
the possibility of indictment and maybe just
as importantly for him global embarrassment
as a result of that indictment. There's actually
an interesting split kind of developing in
the Trump supporter camp, although they all
are still likely to vote for him. In 2020
you've got on one side the Trumpists who are
sort of doubling down and they're pretending
that everything Trump's doing is normal, that
any critique of Trump is merely fake news
meant to take down a president who won't stop
winning.
That's the double down Trumpists, but you've
got this other wing of Trump is developing
there. The Trump is to realize they made a
mistake in supporting this existential threat
to humanity, and they have just stopped paying
attention to Donald Trump and use headlines.
They're sort of pretending that the president,
what? Oh, I, you know, I just work. I go and
live my life. I haven't heard of any of it.
They're sort of struggling to remain ignorant,
deliberately and uninformed for their own
benefit and to placate their cognitive dissonance.
Those are the two sides. Unlikely. Either
side is ultimately to vote for a Democrat,
but we'll talk about that and now let's get
into the specifics of the insanity that this
weekend saw.